how do you describe tough mudder two
people that really are not into exercise
in any extreme form well let's start
with what it's not okay but it's not is
a race it's a challenge about teamwork
and camaraderie most people do it
together and the truth is even if you're
not in great shape you can probably get
through it just by working together as a
team it's 12 miles of military-style
obstacles designed by British special
forces but most of all it's fun and it
might not sound fun to you sitting here
in the studio but it really is a ton of
fun we have 60 events all around the
world this year and you've got the
credibility to put this all together
right because you have a background in
the military well my background is a
civilian counterterrorism officer but I
work very closely with the UK special
forces in my old job so the aim with the
tough mudder to try and recreate that
sense of teamwork in a spree decor so
you really only find in the military and
you put that all together in an
environment that's fun you give someone
a beer at the end of it what's the
challenge starting tough mudder
convincing people that this thing would
really work as a business because I read
that when you were getting your masters
of business yeah at Harvard that you put
this forth as part of the proposal to
try to garner some support didn't fly
but that's exactly right in fact my
professors were pretty pessimistic about
this and said will you have to go and
get yourself a job at McKinsey or
Goldman Sachs because this isn't going
to work in fast forward five years two
million people have done the event we
now have a dedicated research lab
creating all these new obstacles each
year which is one of the reasons we're
here talking today so we have a whole
bunch of new obstacles that we're
launching for 2015 okay if you were
going to put some of those Harvard
professors that turns you down through
the new course yeah what would they go
through well what would they go through
yeah what was some of the opposite so we
would have a king of the swingers so
that's they drop 50 you don't climb 15
foot up over a pit of water you swing
forwards have to grab a trapeze bar and
then you swing on that and you have to
try and hit a bell in the air that's
king of the swingers we have Ring of
Fire you go up a fireman's pole you drop
down through a ring of propane gas it's
about 150 degrees as you go through that
thing it doesn't burn is perfectly safe
i show you into a pool of water
underneath and then we have crybaby
which is an obstacle that takes elements
of tear gas mix that together create a
very disorientating x
interview what you're going through it
but most of all you put these over to
business school professors together it's
about teamwork and camaraderie and
that'll be forced to work together and
put there he goes to one side for a
short period of time how do you think
they do I think they'd get through
they'd have to work together but I'm I'm
joking aside I mean most of them are in
reasonable shape I'm sure they'd be just
fine all right and they would probably
want to go for that beer at the end well
that's right you get a free beer at the
end and this year it's a shock top beer
from anheuser-busch so we've just signed
that I deal with them we're very excited
by that so they're sponsoring our whole
post party afterwards so you get a free
beer at the end of it which is what it's
about as well because you can't take
yourself too seriously when you do a
tough mudder it's about enjoying
yourself it's about being with your
friends it's about challenging yourself
and then it's about having a beer at the
end all right so it's the challenge it's
new sponsors yeah it's new obstacles
it's also new markets France erotic yep
so we're going into Mexico this year we
have three events down there we're also
launching the urban Mudder which is a
five mile event which offers event will
be this summer here in New York
Randall's Island so we have a new event
we also have a children's event the
fruit shoots mini Mudder for 8 to 12
year olds so we're enhancing the
children's experience and the spectator
experience so there's a lot of new
things going on at tmh cute we're very
excited what what does it cost to be a
tough mudder so if you sign up higher
now for the events this summit it can be
as little as 80 to 100 bucks if you wait
until just before the events in six
months time it's gonna be more like 200
bucks all right now is part of our
desire to get to know you a little bit
more I've got some questions for your
building I want to find out what's your
favorite book so my favorite book is a
catch-22 I think it's a great book it's
a satire and I talked about some of the
paradox of war is that it's a great book
it's a reading I've read it twice always
makes me laugh out loud alright so when
you're done with Joseph Heller what
about television what's your favorite TV
program so I house of cards you may be
aware is actually a remake of a british
show so my favorite TV shows the
original british house of cards which
was 15 20 years old now but it's still
as good today as it was then i thought
there was a drop at one point someone
dropped off a whole building and that
that's right yeah i said he's enough
mother he pushes her off the top of the
House of Commons yeah
I was deaf as risky all right what about
a role model for will team yeah so James
Dyson is the founder of a dyson vacuum
of ste gone on to invent a whole bunch
of other products a rare thing a British
entrepreneur there aren't that many of
them is a guy that had an idea it was 10
years of a side business for him and he
turned it into a huge global business
now it's pretty remarkable guy well
you're joining the club with this and
the last thing to you is that your hobby
got a favorite hobby yeah so you know
I've taken up kitesurfing our
kiteboarding as you say in the United
States and I recommend it it's a ton of
fun you need wind and here in New York
you need a very thick wet suit to do it
as well but it's a ton of fun